I haven't made any public comment on it
and I'm not going to start on this show
well everybody has a timeline of the
time that you have to come to vote but I
think that it's likely to be decided
before then and I probably will decide
along with most others I think it's
howard dean who suggested the end of
june but not mistaken it's very
interesting ago I'm from Maine I
represented main in the Senate but I'm
now a resident of New York primarily I
when I left the Senate every mary died
young children my children go to school
here so you're sort of that's what you
end up as a voting taxpaying citizen
when obama won the main carcasses i got
a bunch of letters and calls from people
because they and i thought i'd be a
again a super delegate for me and I've
been a super delegate from Maine since I
love the Senate and they said well Obama
won in Maine so you should vote for
Obama then Clinton won in New York and I
got a few calls from Clinton people
saying well you live in New York you
ought to vote for Clinton because she
won New York and then the Democratic
National Committee announced yes in fact
I would be a dog soup delegate from New
York so then I started getting calls
from my Obama friends making a
completely different argument and both
sides argument have shifted over time if
you say dude should you should I vote in
accordance with the majority in the
state that's New York then I would vote
for Clinton should I vote for the
majority in my congressional district
should I vote for who wins the popular
vote nationwide should that popular vote
include or exclude Florida which is
likely to be deterring factored who with
I mean
each of these has an argument in of
itself by guess my feeling is I feel
much like i did in the senate when I had
to advise it consent on presidential
nominations the Constitution doesn't
define what you do so i think i should
use my best judgment taking into account
and giving great weight to the way
others have voted and there are as i
just mentioned numerous iterations of
that you can look at one of several
factors including the number of
Delegates they have one through the
elective process but in the end making a
judgment which my conscience and
judgment tells me is the person who will
best serve the nation and as a democrat
who will be most likely to be elected if
I did I wouldn't tell you because I
would of course defeat the purpose of
any mediation and I don't so I'm not
giving any secrets from you and I don't
think it's likely to happen I think it's
all going to work out before them I not
not you're not a reporter in the
strictest sense but you know the press
has an interest in controversy keeping
it going and devising scenarios that
suggest a conflict right down to the
last minute of the last hour of the last
roll call at the convention and maybe
beyond but I think reality is to the
country I think it is likely to be
resolved not too long after the last
primary or caucus that's not very far
away we've waited this long we can wait
another month
you